p hex now co-host in fox of fox and
friends weekend and author of the new
book battle for the american mind number
one on the new york times bestseller
live congrats to you pete and welcome
thank you sandra you know we're
glorified by by seeing some of those
that were targeted over the weekend with
violence as a result of the overturning
of roe v wade your thoughts this morning
pete
well we should expect that given what
happened in between the leak of the
draft opinion
to supreme court justices and the actual
decision itself mob violence and the
threat thereof is a tactic used by the
modern left it's not new necessarily to
today but they want their way regardless
of how our system works this ruling was
an absolute validation of our
constitutional republic system you see
they yell about democracy all the time
it's always the word democracy for the
left they use it as a cover word for
everything yet the irony of this
decision is in most of the places as you
pointed out where these riots and
protests are happening abortion on
demand will still be legal in those
states all this decision does is give
the decision back to the people and the
state representatives to make that
decision themselves as opposed to nine
unelected judges dictating the law of
the land so we expect these types of
intimidation and hissy fits and heated
rhetoric but for me i i sit back and say
you know god bless our system and the
wisdom of our founders who made sure
that it wasn't the tyranny of the
majority that would decide where our
rights come from and what is a life
instead our constitution validated our
system and we got a great opinion and
just another one for coach kennedy it's
a wonderful thing to see
great to get his reaction just a moment
ago pete meanwhile i'm sure you watched
the sunday shows over the weekend martha
mccallum was hosting fox news sunday and
she pressed stacy abrams on her
pro-abortion stance here is that moment
watch
if you believe in it all the way up to
nine months you're talking about caring
about the lives of women i'm just asking
at what point do you start to care about
the life of that
baby what i would say is that it is a
medical decision i don't know of a
single woman who reaches the stage where
this decision is easy so i'm going to
take a medically take that as a
up to nine months in some cases
depending on on the woman correct that
is not what i that is not what i said i
said this is a medical decision and the
medical decisions that have to be made
have to be made in context
pete your reaction to that
bravo to martha mccallum and and anytime
a host gets a chance to interview a
democrat about their stance on abortion
that is precisely the line of
questioning you should take at what
point all the way up to nine months
would you say that the life of that
child should be factored in and these
democrats time and time again stacey
abrams the most recent demonstrate and
reveal themselves for the extremists on
this issue that they are you know it's
only countries like the communist
chinese and north korea that have as
abortion on demand policies effectively
we did a segment on fox and friends
weekend this weekend if you look across
europe and most developed western
nations uh the decision in mississippi
was 15 weeks most of them are at 12 or
13 or 14 uh and have been for quite some
time our policy for 50 years has been
extreme they're they're even more
extreme they went from safe legal and
rare to abortion on demand uh good for
her and that's exactly who they are
they're beholden to the pro-abortion
lobby uh and they'll continue that
rhetoric which is way out of step uh
with their voters meanwhile pete in the
wake of the big decision on friday on
roe v wade democrats have renewed their
calls to pack the supreme court the
white house just yesterday finally
confirming that the president has not
changed his position and is still
opposed to expanding the court a new
op-ed argues keeping the court is as is
quote would permanently preserve the
independence of the supreme court if one
party packed the court another party
with a new majority would retaliate by
trying to pack the court again the
result would undermine both the
independence of the court and the rule
of law itself
nine supreme court justices have worked
well since
1869 but a new york times op-ed has this
take and this headline how to discipline
a rogue supreme court the so-called
discipline not only includes packing the
court but adds a push to impeach current
justices democratic congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez pete is on
board
if we allow
supreme court nominees to lie under
earth under oath and secure lifetime
appointments to the highest court of the
land and then issue
issue without basis there must be
consequences for
such a deeply destabilizing action and
hostile takeover of our democratic
institutions
must be consequences for lying supreme
court justices when there's absolutely
no proof that that was the case
no go back and check the tape of how amy
coney barrett and kavanagh and gorsuch
and others answered the question of roe
v wade they did uh what justices for
decades have done they're not going to
give away how they would rule on a
particular
case pending before the court they can
talk about their principles they can
talk about starring decisis they can
talk about a precedent and they did but
they never definitively said anything
one way or the other this is silliness
this is uh juvenile stuff from uh
comrade cortez the socialist but
ultimately it does represent a deep set
of thinking on the left today which
believes if they don't get their way our
system should be torn down uh and
instead our system has validated itself
uh it's easy to defend against this and
thankfully joe biden has found one issue
just one just one where he's willing to
take on the hard left of his party and
say hey guys that's bonkers yeah and
what speaking of my supreme supreme
court um sources on friday making it
very clear that this was just a
misunderstanding of the word precedent
and what it actually means to your point
about those justices and they the way
they viewed this as precedent uh for the
law of the land for those 50 years does
not mean that law cannot change uh was
the point that many were making okay and
the wall street journal editorial board
making that point this morning an mscbc
host meanwhile pete pressed california's
lieutenant governor on her calls to defy
the supreme court listen to this
be prepared to live in defiance of these
six people who think that they have the
right to tell you what you can do
no
i am telling people that they can access
under california law their rights that
were protected by the constitution
that is going to be held in defiance in
some states and i would say yes prepare
to defy
i'm not sure how you react to that but
we heard many calls like that in the
wake of this maxine waters said this on
the steps of the supreme court friday as
well
well this is what they are already doing
when it comes to things like say
sanctuary cities where they don't
enforce immigration law or
da's in these liberal cities who were
refusing to enforce the law themselves
effectively becoming public defenders
they gain the positions and at the ba
and ignore uh the actual rulings from
the supreme court or the law of the land
so that doesn't surprise me one bit
here's the irony too and the sad part of
it is california is going to probably
increase the amount of abortions it
performs again it's not illegal in
california there's nothing to defy it
simply sends it back to the states where
abortion on demand is already the
unfortunate reality in california
again like climate change the politics
of abortion are so central to the lobby
and the democrat party they have to say
these types of things and they do
believe them in many cases um and
unfortunately if you live in california
that is the reality all right pete hex
has great to have you on again crowd
congratulations on the success of your
book appreciate it thank you